taking a family photo is the most
stressful time in my life like no matter
what
kim kardashian can't seem to catch a
break with her kids but the naughtiest
one of all you guessed it north
most of the photos i saw were unusable
because north was sticking out her
middle finger and it's days like this
when i really just need to lock myself
in the room by myself for just a good 30
minutes
right there yeah it's a lot
it's just a lot being a mom
yeah it's pure chaos for kim on the
family's hulu series season finale as
the mama 4 coordinates a photo shoot for
the yearly christmas card yep there's
confusion and crying on set let's go
take a picture
they always cry
nobody gets along
[Applause]
there's a lot of running screaming and
fighting
[Music]
but it's kim's eldest kid on north who
ended up on santa's naughty list after
doing this
most of the photos i saw were unusable
because north was sticking out her
middle finger
okay
i'm coming hey you could never predict
what our christmas card is going to be
like because it's just so stressful i
guess you could say like father like
daughter at least that's what kim once
told us she definitely has kanye's
outgoing personality
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or who it might
offend but it's this kind of behavior
from north that isn't exactly shocking
the nine-year-old tick-tock queen is
known for putting her mom on blast while
recording videos you guys know i love
driver's license
plug she sent a box of tissues there was
also this time when north trolled kim
over her instagram voice guys so today
i've got this new mask and these new
bronzers
i got this
is that way is that what i say is that
what i sound like but back to that
family holiday card now that we scroll
through north is noticeably missing in
most of the shots kim posted and now we
know why but she's not the only one a
lot of the extended family is also m.i.a
including north's dad kanye west who's
estranged from kim as well as courtney's
ex scott disick and chloe's ex tristan
thompson this yearly photo comes on the
heels of the nba star's paternity
scandal where he admitted to cheating on
coco and fathering a baby with fitness
model marylee nichols
christmas is
the biggest deal in our family in light
of what happened with chloe and tristan
i'm trying to bring some happy joyful
moments too all of us i feel like let's
just
try to have happy memories of course
it's a huge tradition to get the
kardashian jenner crew together for the
annual photo op but as we've seen it
doesn't always go according to plan like
in 2018 when kim told et they were stuck
in struggle city this kardashian
christmas card
i i really feel like last year really
[ __ ] us over i'm not going to lie it
really did us in so
we gotta get it together
we gotta plan ahead wise advice kim
hopefully for 2022 less fingers most of
the photos i saw were unusable because
north was sticking out her middle finger
and more being festive
[Music]